c'est avec stupeur que la nouvelle est
tombée hier en fin de journée gérard
depardieu mise en examen pour viol
gérard depardieu a été mise en examen
la mise en examen pour viols et
agressions sexuelles de gérard depardieu
ne se passe pas une semaine sans qu'une
célébrité ne se retrouve au coeur d'une
affaire de moeurs cette fois ci c'est
l'acteur de 72 ans qui est au coeur
d'une enquête suite à une plainte
déposée en 2018 par une batterie d'une
vingtaine d'années selon la jeune femme
l'acteur aurait abusé d'elle à deux
reprises à son domicile parisien dans le
6ème arrondissement
une plainte qui en 2009 avait d'abord
été classée sans suite avant que le
dossier soit rouvert en 2020 selon le
parisien les enquêteurs ont pu se
procurer les vidéos des caméras de
surveillance du domicile de l'acteur
dans lesquels on y voit les deux
comédiens discuter gérard depardieu
pratiquer une pénétration digitale à la
jeune actrice avant qu'ils ne montent à
l'est d'âge selon l'avocat de gérard
depardieu hervé temime
l'acteur se défend de ces accusations
gérard depardieu conteste totalement les
faits qui lui sont reprochés
alors êtes vous choqué par les
accusations de viol contre gérard
depardieu alors les jacks et la
plaignante alors si on connaît pas sa
véritable identité la plaignante serait
une jeune comédienne et danseuse âgé
d'une vingtaine d'années passées par le
cours florent à l'orée connu gérard
depardieu par son père qui serait un ami
de l'acteur qui évolue lui même dans le
milieu artistique toujours selon les
sources gérard depardieu la plaignante
aurait été régulièrement en contact par
téléphone
l'acteur lui prodiguant ses conseils
pour sa carrière la tenant la plaignante
je vous dis n'a pas tenu à s'exprimer
son avocate a demandé que l'intimité la
vie privée de sa cliente soit préservé
alors que s'est-il passé
merci en tout cas à roland perez d'être
là merci beaucoup et c'est vrai que
c'est toujours un plaisir de nous avoir
et là c'est vrai que ça on a pris un
coup sur la tête avec cette affaire
parce que c'est vrai qu'on s'en est
jamais caché on aime énormément gérard
depardieu dans cette émission du rare qu
était le parrain d'ailleurs de cette
saison un stade et c'est toujours
d'ailleurs le parrain de 2,2 de touche
pas à mon poste cette saison et gérard
depardieu sur accusé de deux viols et
d'agressions sexuelles qui auraient eu
lieu à son domicile parisien dans le
quartier n'ont pas c'était le 7 août 10
2018 orieux la première agression
d'abord dans le salon l'acteur puis dans
une chambre à l'étagé de son domicile et
une semaine après cette pression mais la
création de 13 août la jeune comédienne
aurait selon elle été prise dans un
mécanisme de sidération et de dénis et
serait retournée au domicile de l'acteur
il y aurait su alors subi un second viol
alors ça serait de semaine après les
faits que la jeune femme se serait
confié à ses proches sur ces agressions
résumé elle aurait alors déposé plainte
contre gérard depardieu à la gendarmerie
de laon baisse dans les bouches du rhône
une enquête qui sera ensuite confiée à
la pj parisienne selon voilà des sources
et il se trouve que l'affairé a été
classée sans suite
exactement là où tu parce que ni la
jeune comédienne qui accuse gérard
depardieu explique que l'exécution ait
eu lieu à son domicile de l'acteur il se
trouve
et ça c'est une information que personne
n'avait que dans l'hôtel particulier du
rar depardieu il ya des caméras de
surveillance dans le salon qu'ont pu
analyser les policiers et un éléments
permettraient d'en savoir un peu plus
sur ce qui s'est passé
on y voit lors de leur première
rencontre les deux comédiens discuter
puis le célèbre acteur pratiquer une
pénétration digitale à la jeune actrice
avant qu'ils ne montent à l'étagé l'un
après l'autre ou aucune mike cameron est
installée la plaignante affirme avoir
suivi l'acteur sous l'effet de la
tétanie outre les caméras de
surveillance les ans que les enquêteurs
vont également s'intéresser aux
téléphones portables des deux
protagonistes
je cite l'exploitation des téléphones
des deux comédiens révèle de nombreux
échanges troublant dont un dans lequel
gérard depardieu compare sa jeune
consoeur à la chanteuse barbara mais
selon une source proche de l'enquêté
ces échanges explicite n'ont pas mis en
évidence de pressions de la part de
l'acteur l'acteur aurait également été
entendu le 27 novembre 2018 pour cette
affaire en audition libre
suite à cet entretien il n'avait pas été
placé en garde à vue et finalement après
neuf mois d'investigations la plainte
pour viol et agression sexuelle visant
l'acteur est classée sans suite par le
parquet de paris selon une source
judiciaire
les infractions dénoncées n'ont pas pu
être caractérisées roland perez
on voit ça a été que la saison puis
pourquoi ça ressort aujourd'hui alors un
classement sans suite c'est généralement
à la suite d'une enquête qui est fait à
la demande du procureur donc c'est une
enquête préliminaire on demande à des
brigades d'investir d'investir
investiguez de comme vous l'avez
expliqué de regarder les téléphones
portables d'asus youn et cher parfois
des confrontations
et puis classement sans suite ya pas
s'il n'y a pas de suffisamment
d'éléments accablants
et puis alors du coup la victime décide
de déposer plainte cette fois ci avec
constitution de partie civile est là
quasiment alors sa constitution de
partie civile ça veut dire qu'on va
demander la daisy
a sion d'un juge d'instruction pour une
information d'initié aire d'accueil dans
la plupart des cas dans 90% des cas ça
oblige
effectivement la justice a désigné un
juge d'instruction
et là la difficulté c'est que le juge
d'instruction n'était pas d'accord avec
finalement ce que le procureur avait
décidé quasiment neuf mois plus tôt
puisque là une information est ouverte
et surtout une mise en examen est faite
de gérard depardieu
alors donc la fête était ensuite donc là
ils vont reprendre tous les éléments de
la faire c'est ça ils vont reprendre les
éléments de la faire ils vont prend pas
le moment peut-être essayer de
confronter une fois de plus les deux
personnes savez dans ces affaires de
fioles le la frontière et y at il eu
consentement ou non plus at il eu une
volonté ou non d'avoir des relations
sexuelles consenties c'est ce qu'on
appelle les relations sexuelles
consenties ou non consenti
qui peut déterminer l'existence d'une
infraction civile agressions sexuelles à
l'emprise c'est ce qu'elle dit alors
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que on voit dans
un certain nombre d'affaires
cette définition un peu de l'emprise
c'est à dire de la relation la
soumission est ce que ça devant les
tribunaux ça peut tenir en fait le juge
d'instruction lui il met en examen
quelqu'un et à la fin il va instruire à
charge et à décharge s'il a suffisamment
d'éléments accablants il va finalement
renvoyé devant le tribunal où la cour
d'assises si mathien l'histoire du viol
et là c'est une cour d'assises qui va
juger des éléments
le juge d'instruction lui ne fait que
préparer enquêter encadrer la faire et
faire en sorte que la sphère ce
finalement jugés soit par un tribunal
soit par une cour d'assises
en fonction de la gravité finalement
défait alors c'est pas le biais de son
avocat maître hervé temime que gérard
depardieu a contesté les t il écouté ce
qu'il a dit ce matin sur france à chilly
à une affaire où la présente une sens a
plus de sens que jamais c'est celle
fille cette enquête a fait l'objet d'un
classement sans suite
ce qui signifiait que le parquet
considérait qu'il n'y avait pas lieu à
poursuivre jardin par dieu par ailleurs
je déplore profondément que cette
nouvelle soit rendue publique
car nous étions dans une situation assez
exceptionnelle pendant deux mois
aucune information n'avait filtré ce
dossier n'a pas
être sur la place publique donc laissons
travailler la justice et respecter les
droits de chacun
tu verrais ce que vous avez des doutes
c'est une affaire très étrange
effectivement la mise en examen date du
16 décembre
aujourd'hui j'ai appelé l'avocat de la
plaignante m joyon hibon qui refusent
qui n'a pas voulu parler qui n'a pas
voulu rappeler parce qu'elle ne veut
communiquer aucun élément sur l'identité
la personnalité de la plaignante
c'est une volonté de secret qu est très
étrange et on avait l'impression que des
deux côtés puisque gérard depardieu a
été laissé libre sans contrôle
judiciaire
faut bien préciser libres sans contrôle
aux affaires était classé non non non
même si même s'il est mis en examen
considère qu'il est suffisamment
représentées suffisamment accessible il
ne s'est pas dérobé à la première
confrontation effectivement comme dit m
perez il y aura sans doute une deuxième
confrontation mais ce qui est étrange
c'est la volonté des deux côtés m -t me
pour deux par dieu qui dit on aurait pas
dû médiatisé et l'avocat de la
plaignante qui elle non plus ne veut pas
médiatisé c'est très inhabituel dans ses
affaires
reste maintenant à savoir d'où vient la
source moi je vais vous donner mon
sentiment après l' enquête que j'ai fait
aujourd'hui j'ai un tout petit peu
l'impression sont du tout prendre parti
sur les faits bien entendu que quelqu'un
au niveau de la justice a eu envie que
ça sorte
pour médiatiser en ce moment comme par
hasard la sphère depardieu je vous donne
mon sentiment après enquête
d'aujourd'hui la corse et ses voitures
qui vont justement une question à ce
propos à roland perez est ce que c'est
ça arrive souvent que un magistrat
plaies de l' inverse de du parquet parce
que le parquet avait dit non lieu est un
magistrat qui dit ah ben non moi je suis
pas d'accord avec le parquet parce que
là il y dix même d'aider des indices
graves et concordants alors comment tout
d'un coup y avait pas d'indicés graves
et concordants et là pourquoi c'est tout
c'est l'avant c'est toute la partialité
de la justice c'est à dire que la
justice est rendue par les hommes
différents évidemment donc on a un parc
et y est on a un procureur de la
république au vu des éléments estimés
qui avait pas d'éléments suffisamment
accablant pour aller plus loin que l'umq
avait été ouverte qui a classé cette
affaire monde estimant que les faits
n'étaient pas constitués les faits de
viol ou d'agression sexuelle n'était pas
constituée et puis on a un juge
d'instruction qui devant les mêmes
éléments truquer les éléments gras
avec qu'il ya des éléments concordants
et lui ouais décide d'ouvrir cette fois
ci à la fois une information et surtout
de mettre en examen
alors ce qui est terrible est ce que ce
que disait avait temime
ce qui est terrible c'est pas c'est pas
le fait de dire parce que juste dire que
quelqu'un est mise en examen ou doit
comprendre dans l'esprit de tout le
monde que cela veut pas dire que la
personne est coupable il mêle reste
présumé innocent mais la difficulté
c'est que vous et moi peut-être qu'on
peut peut-être parfois comprendre ces
subtilités mais dans l'esprit du public
le public histoire de pargesa devoir due
à la mise en examen oui il est déjà
présumé coupable ça je sais que ça et ça
c'est terrible ça c'était ça ça me
dérange parce que on laisse pas de
chance à la vérité c'est-à-dire qu'on
laisse pas la chance à la vérité dans un
tribunal médiatique on doit la chance à
la vérité on doit l'avoir dans un
tribunal où il ya une impartialité où il
ya des gens qui connaissent les règles
les règles du contradictoire le respect
du contradictoire chacun doit avoir son
moment pour exprimer ce soit la victime
évidemment avec ce soit celui qui a mis
tant de l'udc est mis en cause mais
malheureusement lorsque c'est à faire
des passes évidemment ce le tribunal
pour pour entrer dans la sphère
médiatique
et bien tout le monde se fait ce serait
finalement une vision sans avoir des
saignements d'année médiatiquement en
fait oui les cons et les médias sur
gérard depardieu il se passe pas la même
chose sur les autres ménages aux leçons
sommités que c'est vrai que ça j'ai
l'impression que je dis moi ça parle
beaucoup n'a pas beaucoup c'est vrai
mais quand ça se fait ça d'abord gérard
depardieu c'est une carrière
internationale
c'est quelqu'un qui a toujours eu son
franc parler c'est quelqu'un qui dans sa
personnalité ne laisse entrevoir une
certaine il assume ses actes il assume
qu'il il assume ses opinions politiques
il assume ses essais ses virages et donc
on se dit pourquoi pourquoi ils
n'auraient pas à assumer s'il y avait eu
éventuellement ce type de d'actes qui
nous a menti de vos pensées et comme l'a
sous-entendu cerner ce que vous pensez
qu'il ya un magistrat qui voulait se
payer
gerrard ça j'ai du mal j'ai du mal à
démarrer
j'ai du mal et on j'ai du mal à le
penser j'ai dû à sa pensée que alors et
c'est sorti deux mois après c'est vrai
que c'est un peu curieux que ce soit
sorti deux mois après mais ce qui est
sorti c'est pa on
pas violé le secret de l'instruction n'a
pas donné d'éléments de la cie pourtant
on a juste dit quelqu'un une
personnalité était mise en examen et
c'est vrai que il ya deux poids deux
mesures vous n'êtes pas connu la victime
n'est pas connue où le prévenu n'est pas
connu personne n'en parle
et c'est une arme supplémentaire quand
une personne est connue parce que ça
ajoute aujourd'hui c'est une atteinte à
sa réputation c'est sûr c'est une
atteinte à sa réputation il ya eu des
nouvelles de gérard depardieu qui sait
quand il va gérer j'annule par voie de
conséquence par le point mon copain du
point par bd est bon évidemment sous le
choc mais surtout ce qui l'a rendu fou
c'est que et et vous l'avez dit m c'est
que depardieu c'est un personnage
truculent donc qui sait que voilà force
est prêt si on dit que c'est une bête
alors ça joue évidemment contre lui et
ce qui est terrible une fois de plus et
ce qui moi moi je me désole c'est une
question d'ailleurs à avallon et que une
fois de plus on va dire il n'y a pas de
fumée sans feu et ça on est pour autant
peut pas non plus un autre en cause une
amanite ont la parole de notre essai des
questions que moi dans ce cas là c'est
que pour l'instant c'est parole contre
parole non pour moi ya deux victimes
gérard depardieu et la victime et c'est
valable pour d'autres affaires mais au
rythme où ça va m il y en a une tous les
trois jours qui sort alors première
question est ce que là ils peuvent
trouver un arrangement et qu'on peut
abandonner les choses bien sûr à la
tendance est encore sahar et bien sûr
bien sûr là la victime peut se rétracter
peut estimer qu'en réalité elle était
peut-être alors c'est peut-être pas le
cas du tout mais elles peuvent estimer
avoir été un peu affaibli
psychologiquement avoir pu croire à
quelque chose à cette emprise qui en
réalité n'existait pas ou penser que
cette emprise n'était pas n'était pas le
fait peut-être de de gérard depardieu
donc oui bien sûr elle peut toujours
revenir
qu'est ce qui se passe quand on est lavé
de tout soupçon et que effectivement au
final tout ça est entièrement est
basiquement faut qu'elle ait le recours
que moi je pars moi je dis moi un mois
être humain j'ai contre eux une fosse à
des accusations contre les conséquences
dramatiques que ça peut avoir sur ma vie
parce que laisser derrière d'aidés
d'état
ça s'appelle la dénonciation calomnieuse
d'accord et la dénonciation calomnieuse
et dans notre code pénal également elle
permet la location dommages et intérêts
la difficulté c'est que médiatiquement
on n'en parle jamais c'est à dire que
une fois que les personnes ont été
sorties de cette affaire on revient
c'est un peu moins spectaculaire ça
intéresse un peu moins les médias et les
actions menées en dénonciation
calomnieuse
sont rarement médiatisé mais ça existe
vraiment et je comprends qu'ils aient
voulu la discrétion tout le monde a
voulu la discrétion dans cette affaire
malheureusement ces sorties à la faveur
d'un magistrat qu'a voulu se taper le
parquet ça c'est ce qui arrive en
général à la mer du parquet mais bon
c'est quand même cette présomption
d'innocence qui est bafouée
systématiquement je rappelle que maître
hervé team et minimes est également
l'avocat de richard berry julia à chaque
fois c'est le même problème c'est à dire
que c'est mis sur la place publique
il est condamné d'avancé moi j'entends
des commentaires ou même sur les réseaux
sociaux ni comme a dit benjamin ya de
vie qui vient aussi la jeune femme est
bien chez voilà il y avait bien sûr
l'instant il ya de victimes après on
verra vrai bien sûr mais qui est
coupable et qui a la parole de tétanie
etc
mais alors il ya ces histoires de
caméras quand même qu'il semble assez
clair et puis après on alors qu'est-ce
qu'elle tisse des caméras elle met les
caméras ils sont sur un canapé on les
boiteries diable j'ai dit oui a été
relatée dans le paris de ce qui a été
relaté absolument et on a appris
d'ailleurs qui a pas de caméra dans la
chambre de depardieu
voilà maintenant ça m'est très difficile
maintenant ce qu'elle défend elle cette
jeune fille j'espère que c'est faux pour
elle elle parle de tétanie est donc l
excuse un peu tout ça comme ça merci en
tout cas y avoir de toutes façons des
expertises psychologiques qui ont été
menées sur tout le monde est sur la
victime évidemment haussière si roland
perez